I'm originally from Aiken South Carolina
but I am now a general surgeon in
Anniston Alabama halfway between Atlanta
and Birmingham
so with without the animation a typical
gallbladder visit may take 20 minutes
I'm in that 20 minutes five minutes at
the end is spent prompting the patient
to answer questions as well as to ask
questions so a lot of times they'll come
in and are not familiar enough with the
gallbladder so they don't even know what
questions to ask versus when we use the
animation because we're utilizing that
time that I'm not in the room we take
five minutes out of that initial visit
but the patient still gets all of their
questions answered so what happens is in
turn I get about five minutes per
patient per video every day so if I have
two or three gallbladders if I have a
colon operation if I have an inguinal
hernia operation that saves me about
20-25 minutes which from a Productivity
standpoint is an extra patient visit or
I can spend that time with other
patients that have more difficult
problems that need more
when I forget to put the videos on they
remind me to put the videos oh because
what happens is they now get to walk in
ask the patient hey did you see the
video do you have any questions about
the video there used to patients saying
no I saw the video I'm good what's the
next step
versus when the videos are all the
nurses do spend a lot more time in there
answering questions after I leave so
they love the videos probably as much if
not more than I do you know if you add
from a surgical standpoint if you add
the amount of money that the video calls
per year versus the amount of patients
that you see because you've become more
effective and more efficient I would say
the videos probably pay for themselves
after about two or three patient visits